here with more well he knows a lot about
dealing with illegal immigration Texas
governor Greg Abbott is with us Tech
Governor how are you
doing great Sean thank you
so wait I you might be a little
surprised to hear this New York Governor
hokel said to illegal immigrants if
you're going to leave your country go
somewhere else
uh Eric Adams is slamming Joe Biden over
the illegal immigration crisis because
he's going to have to pay a whopping uh
12 billion dollars to take care of them
it's forty thousand dollars per illegal
immigrant New York City
um aren't these the same people that
were supporting Sanctuary policies
They promoted Sanctuary City policies
they were saying that they wanted to
take care of any immigrant who comes
across the border and so we made it
happen uh in New York uh and to be
honest they have just a trickle of what
Texas has to do with every single day
and if they should get 12 billion
dollars Texas should get a 120 billion
dollars we're the ones who have to deal
with this every single day Sean and I
got to tell you we have a president who
is an obstructionist to Texas who's
trying to do our best to impede the flow
of illegal immigrants by us building our
own border wall by us putting up these
razor wire barriers and not allowing
people to pass by deploying the National
Guard to make sure that we repel
migrants who are trying to get into the
country and what do we have we have Joe
Biden interfering with my efforts to
secure the actual border I've never seen
a president flout the laws of the United
States as much as Joe Biden and I've
never seen someone like that obstruct a
governor who actually is trying to limit
illegal immigration into our country let
me tell you I hope you continue to send
them all to New York all to California
and all of Massachusetts send them up to
Illinois as well I think it's the
greatest political Jiu Jitsu move I've
ever seen in my life uh you you they're
tapping out at this point they don't
even want any part of it did they knock
Administration and did they not have
officials cut your razor wire that you
put up to protect the borders of your
state that they won't protect
your correction so the Texas National
Guard for months after months after
months they've been erecting these razor
wire barriers as Constantine military
grade razor wire that denies access to
the state of Texas from the river from
the border and we have repelled tens of
thousands of migrants to try to get into
Texas illegally and then yesterday Joe
Biden had his border patrol officers cut
through that razor wire and then they
pulled the razor wire and suddenly let
in hundreds if not thousands of people
illegally into Texas into the United
States so what did we do we went back
today with the Texas National Guard and
we doubled the amount of razor wire on
that border to make sure we keep those
people from entering into the United
States governor let me ask you this
question if I if I went down to the
great state of Texas the free state of
Texas and I started clipping and cutting
an opening for illegal immigrants would
I be found guilty likely arrested and
found guilty of human trafficking
it's called criminal destruction of
property as well as trespassing so one
thing that we have the National Guard
and the Texas Department of Public
Safety doing when you see those people
coming into the state of Texas illegally
and if they're involved in damaging that
wire and then coming into our land they
are trespassing in the state of Texas we
are now arresting illegal immigrants for
trespassing in the state of Texas and
putting them in jail
we appreciate it
[Applause]
Adams of New York I urge every
Democratic Sanctuary City supporter to
go down and visit you and tour the
Border let them see up close and
personal what you have to deal with
every day thank you Governor appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else